folks it would appear that my agent is  the worst  person in the world  but you can put these cameras  in your glasses  in a in a your front pocket lapel what i  do is pick a target who are you gonna  why  are you putting that stapler in my face  no that's not a stupid thing yes it is  you know i get that all the time  you wouldn't believe that  you wouldn't uh no call me jared  that is a huge digital camera taped to a  green mardi gras necklace i'm just  following orders here okay that's what  you specifically said to do necklace  hidden camera in a necklace hidden  it's in the necklace right here it's on  the necklace for okay you know what  this is a bad day  you are  his doppelganger there's no doubt no no  i know i get that all the time there's  no doubt about it